joe biden does not look like he's long
for this presidency joe biden doesn't
look like he's long for this world joe
biden just gave an update last night he
was giving an update on january 6th and
trying to ramp up his attacks about the
republicans and trump in january 6.
the guy gave a zombified press
conference
that that made you think
the man is not well
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-cop you can't be pro-insurrection
and pro-democracy you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-american donald
trump lacked the courage to act
the brave women and men in blue all
across this nation
should never forget that
so forget for a second that his voice is
just completely different than it
normally is it's he sounds like he
sounds like joe biden doing one of those
anonymous interviews that gangsters do
regardless smashing up the voice he's
got the voice is all crazy
but then the weirdest part of the the
interview
or the press conference rather
is that he doesn't blink
that whole talk he doesn't blink once
his eyes are super wide puper's pupils
dilated they're obviously
pumping this guy up with something
he's got more energy than he's ever had
in a kind of weird stilted robotic way
he wouldn't be the first democrat
president to be injected with uppers in
the white house john f kennedy famously
had that happen to him from dr feelgood
and it stands to reason that joe biden
would need this too joe biden was
already 21 years old when president
kennedy was having this happen to him
the man is obviously past his prime he's
obviously
not in control of himself much less the
country and it does raise the question
who is calling the shots here right now
go to rockauto.com enter knowles in
there how did you hear about us box do
you ever get frustrated when a salesman
tries to sell you a product that he
knows absolutely nothing about usually
just because it's the most expensive
thing you go to a restaurant you say
what kind of wine do you recommend they
always point to the most expensive wine
on the menu you go into any kind of
store you say what kind of shoes should
i buy they say buy the most expensive
shoes right even though they're not the
right shoes for you drives me crazy this
is one of the things i love about
rockauto.com these guys are not trying
to push the shiniest or the most
expensive product or the product with
the most marketing behind it they sell
auto parts because it's what they know
and they sell the ones that work for you
and there's no hidden agenda here
they're not trying to push this one part
over the other you go on to rockauto.com
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you go
they've got a super easy to navigate
website you find exactly the part you
need for the make the model of your car
or truck same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers no gimmicks go to
rockauto.com get the brake shocks carpet
wipers headlights mirrors mufflers lug
nuts or any other part you need
rockauto.com and then be sure to write
knowles in their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
there's been a big debate over puberty
blockers and cross-sex hormones and all
sorts of weird transgender drugs not
just for adults but for little tiny kids
puberty blockers kids can go on those at
eight years old
okay and there's been a big debate over
this and the white house the biden white
house where the assistant secretary of
health is a man who thinks that he's a
woman
who is very very in favor of injecting
little tiny kids with these sorts of
drugs and the left-wing establishment
in its entirety has gotten behind this
transing the kids campaign
and then the conservative said hey
hold up
i think maybe it's not a great idea to
inject tiny little kids with a bunch of
chemicals to make them look more like
the opposite sex maybe we should hold
off on this a little bit until we
there's no way even if you buy into
transgenderism there's no way that this
can really be good for the kids and the
libs said we're anti-science and we're
crazy and we're bigots and we're phobic
and we're this and we're that so the fda
earlier this month just added a warning
to puberty blockers specifically to
gonadotropin
releasing hormone agonists
gnrh but that's that's what we're
talking about when we talk about puberty
blockers
the warning indicates the risks for the
little tiny kids who take these drugs
the fda identified six cases in females
between the ages of 5 and 12 who were
taking these puberty blockers
which presented quote a plausible
association between gnrh agonist use and
pseudotumor cerebri
what are pseudo
tumor cerebri that's also known as
idiopathic intracranial hypertension it
this means that your brain swells up
that's what's happening when we inject
these little kids with the puberty
blockers in enough cases that the fda
now has to add a warning label kids uh
skull
the pressure entire inside kids skulls
spontaneously increases this causes
brain swelling severe headaches nausea
double vision and permanent vision loss
this according to the mayo clinic this
according to the fda this is what we're
doing when richard levine gets up there
in his little skirt with his long hair
and he says for my equality so that i
can feel really good about my delusions
we need to pump little tiny confused
kids full of drugs that are going to
make their brains swell and make them go
blind to say nothing of the other
problems that these drugs cause because
when they get a little bit older and
they go on the cross-sex hormones those
drugs are causing osteoporosis they're
causing they're causing young otherwise
would-be healthy people to become
crippled all to justify the delusions of
these sick grown men who should be in
counseling if not outright
institutionalized and instead what we've
done
is put them in charge of health in our
country can you imagine how sick that is
can you imagine of course you can
imagine it we're living through it right
now
these are the geniuses
these are the public health people these
are the people running our country doing
this
and they say trust the science and they
say trust the fouchy and they say trust
the richard levine i don't have trust
for any of these people if an african
witch doctor and shaman walked in here
with a headdress and a big cauldron full
of
bones and bats and
double double toil and trouble or
whatever they've got that dates back 5
000 years i would trust that man's
medical opinion much more than i would
trust the medical opinion of dr richard
levine or dr fauci and i think a lot of
people are waking up to that fact right
now if if a political regime would do
this one they're not to be trusted when
it comes to their faculties of reason
they don't know true from false
but two it's just so freaking evil it's
so evil to do this to little kids all to
justify the delusions of
mentally ill or sexually perverted grown
men it's just so
so wrong you feel it in your bones you
feel it so
deeply
and everyone knew this everyone knew
even for some of the people who
maybe
don't have medical degrees which i guess
is most of us you don't need a medical
degree to know that pumping kids full of
these chemicals is not good for them
okay and now all of a sudden the white
lab coats are catching up well actually
maybe this isn't maybe it isn't so good
to pump little tiny kids full of all
these drugs well we're going to keep
doing it anyway because they disregard
the science and they disregard the
philosophy and they disregard the
natural law and they just pursue their
own
radical delusions
i'm glad you like that clip folks
we're there
we did it well it kind of depends
because we're at a million subscribers
but then i've been talking to people
this morning and they say michael for
whatever reason i was unsubscribed from
your channel so i think there may be
some shenanigans going on over with our
friends at youtube either way we're
teetering on any given moment 999 999 or
1 million thank you for bringing us
there maybe ring that bell subscribe
make sure that we are over that
threshold then i will get my trophy then
youtube will nuke my channel and hey it
will have been fun see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you